ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันอังคารค่ะวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 7
เดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนมิถุนายน
ปีพตอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
2565 เขียนผิดเองนะคะ
ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วัน
อะไรคะเมื่อวานนี้วันจันทร์วันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะวันที่ 6 เดือนอะไรเมื่อเดือน
มิถุนายนปีพตตปีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศปีคศ 2  022 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วัน
อะไรคะพรุ่งนี้วันพุธ
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 8 ค่ะเดือน
มิถุนายน EP พ.ต.มีพ.ศ
2565 ปีคศ
ปีพ.ศ 2  022 ค่ะป่าตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงคะ
ครูป๊าตอนนี้เวลา 12:00 น
เที่ยงกี่นาที
เที่ยง 25 นาทีค่ะนัด 12:20  5 นาทีมีสี
นะคะเป็นเวลากลางวันมาถ้าครูฟ้าแล้วก็ครู
หญิงเนี่ยเมื่อก่อนใช่ไหมตอนนี้เนี่ยปี
2022 ครูฝากครูฟ้ากับครูหญิงเนี่ยไม่ได้
เรียนหนังสือแล้ว
อาหารแต่ว่า
เรียนจบแล้วใช่ไหมแต่ถ้าของครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ย้อนอะสิบปีที่แล้วเนาะ
2012 ครูฟ้าเนี่ยเรียนหนังสือ
ไทยค่ะหนังสือแต่งผู้หญิงอาจจะ 20 ปีที่
แล้ว
ของคุยกับนี้ของครูบาใช่ไหมอันนี้ของครู
หญิง 20 ปี
ผู้หญิงเรียกนี่
ชายค่ะ 20 ปีที่แล้วเนี่ย
2002 ครูหญิงเนี่ยเรียนหนักมีหรือใช่ไหม
ตอนครูฟ้าครูหญิงเรียนหนังสือเนี่ยเราชอบ
ชอบตอนเที่ยงคุณฟ้าชอบไหมตอนเที่ยงชอบค่ะ
เพราะผู้ชายจะได้กินข้าว
ชายครูหญิงก็จะได้กินข้าวใช่ไหมแต่ถ้า
เป็นแบบ
8:00 น
9:00 นวันนี้เนี่ยครูฟ้ากับครูหญิงอ่ะ
ต้องเรียนเรียนหนังสือ
เรียนหนังสือ
เราเรียนหนังสือที่ไหนคะคือฟ้า
เราเรียนหนังสือที่โรงเรียนค่ะใส่แล้วค่ะ
นี้โรงเรียนโรงเรียนก็ต้องมีธงชาติไทยใช่
ไหมคะสีแดง
สีน้ำเงินสีขาวก่อนไหมไม่รู้ค่ะกูฟ้าถ้า
คุณเนี่ยนักเรียนอ่านนี้สีน้ำเงินนั้นบอก
ตรงกลางสีอะไรใช่ไหมตรงงานสีขาวไงคะแล้ว
ก็นี้สีแดงนกคุณก็ไม่ค่อยรู้เหมือนกันนะ
คะ
คุณก็ลืมแล้วนะอันนี้ก็สีแดงสมัยนี้ก็สี
แดงหา L สีน้ำเงินอันนี้คือธงชาติไทย
สวยไหมอ่ะโอเคนะพี่นัดที่โรงเรียนเนี่ย
เวลาเราเรียนหนังสือ
ก็เวลาครูฟ้าเด็กๆครูฟ้าชอบไปโรงเรียนไหม
เวลาครูฟ้าเด็กๆครูฟ้าชอบไปโรงเรียนค่ะ
ครูหญิงเวลาที่เราไปโรงเรียนเนี่ยเราก็
เรียนหนังสือใช่ไหมครูฟ้าเนี่ยชอบไปโรง
เรียนแล้วชอบเรียนหนังสือไหน
ไม่ชอบ
เวลาให้ฟ้าไปมี
อะไรคะที่ไหนต่อหนังสือ
หนังสือนะทรายเวลาครูฟ้าไปโรงเรียนเนี่ย
เวลาเราไปโรงเรียนน้องนักเรียนไปโรงเรียน
ก็เหมือนกัน
เราก็ต้องไปเรียนหนังสือ
1 วันเนี่ยครูฟ้าเรียนประมาณกี่วิชา
วะนะปะนะ
ประมาณ 7 วิชา
7 วิชาก็อาจจะมีวิชาเลขเนาะนึกสแควรูท 1
*  2  / ด้วยสแควรูท 8 เท่ากับเท่าไหร่
อันนี้วิชาเลข
ชาลีอ้าว่าวิชาเคมี
เคมี
แมกม่า
วิชาเคมีใช่มั้ยแคลเซียมออกซิเจนโอ้นี่มา
ชายค่ะก็เป็นวิชาครูฟ้านะเรียน 7 วิชาผู้
หญิงมีคำถามค่ะครูฟ้าผู้หญิงถามว่าอะไรคะ
กริ่งถามว่าเวลาครูพระเรียนหนังสือที่โรง
เรียนเนี่ยครูฟ้าชอบนะขอเรียนวิชาอะไรมาก
ที่สุด
ตอนที่กูฟ้าเรียนหนังสือหรือที่โรงเรียน
ลบเนาะ
ชอบเอาชอบกี่อันชอบหนึ่งค่ะมากที่สุด
เนี่ยหนึ่ง
ชอบหน่อย
ชอบมาที่สุดก็คือ
1 หรอเอาแค่ 1 นะ 1
วิชา
อะไรอ่ะเราชอบอะไรก็ไปคิดว่ากูปลาชอบ
ชื่อภาษาอังกฤษอ่ะโอเคค่ะฟ้าชอบเรียนวิชา
ภาษาอังกฤษ
มากที่สุดมากที่สุด
ทำไม
เพราะว่ากูฟ้าเนี่ยเป็นคนชอบใช่มั้ยชอบ
เรียนภาษา
ภาษาอังกฤษภาษาจีน
ภาษาญี่ปุ่นอะไรเงี้ยฟ้าเรียน 2 นะคะ
เรียนภาษาอังกฤษแล้วก็ภาษาจีน
ครูฟ้าชอบเรียนภาษาอังกฤษเพราะว่าครูฟ้า
ชอบเรียนภาษา
รอบเรียนภาษาที่ก็คิดเองเอริดหรือว่าจีน
เพราะกูฟ้าก็ชอบภาษาจีนกันน้าอ่อนรู้สึก
ว่าชอบเรียนภาษาสมัยจะได้ดูหนังดูซีรี่
ภาษาอังกฤษโอเคดูซีรีส์ภาษาจีนได้และ
ก็เลยคะก็เลยชอบวิชาที่ชอบเรียนก็คือวิชา
ภาษาภาษาอังกฤษภาษาจีนจะไม่มีภาษาไทยไม่
ความไม่ไม่ชอบภาษาไทยยังไม่ได้ถามยังยัง
ไม่ใช่ภาษาไทยน่ะผู้หญิงผู้หญิงอบเรียน
อะไรมากที่สุดผู้หญิงเหมือนครูฟ้าผู้หญิง
ก็ผู้หญิงก็ชอบเรียน
ซอฟต์เรียนวิชาภาษาอังกฤษเหมือนครูฟ้าค่ะ
ชอบมากที่สุด
ทำไม
ทำไมผู้หญิงเนี่ยเมื่อก่อน
คอบฟังเพลงอะไรก็อาจจะมีหูฟัง
นี่แหละคะลูกค้ารู้ใช่ไหมมี
วงฟางหูฟังใช้ผู้หญิงเนี่ยชอบฟังเพลงภาษา
อังกฤษ
นิดนี่สปีเซียรู้จักไหมคะ
อะไรก็ Virgin อร์
ไมเคิลแจ็กสันใช่ไหม Justin  Bieber
Selena ดี้กาก้าได้อ่าเป็นทั้งหมดเนี่ย
เขาเป็นนักร้องสมัยร้องเพลงเป็นภาษา
อังกฤษคู่หญิงเรียนชอบฟังเพลงภาษาอังกฤษ
ก็เลยคิดถ้าเราเรียนภาษาอังกฤษแล้วก็เก่ง
ก็ฟังเพลงภาษาอังกฤษเนี่ยโอ้เข้าใจเข้าใจ
ว่าร้องอะไรก็เลยชอบเรียนวิชาภาษาอังกฤษ
มากค่ะดีมากเลยผู้หญิงวิ่งก็ชอบภาษา
อังกฤษเหมือนคล้ายๆกรูฟ้าใช่ไหมครูฟ้า
เนี่ยดูซีรีย์ไม่ใช่ไหมดูหนัง
อาญามีอังกฤษค่ะว่าจะไปออสเตรเลียคะ
เออสเตด
ครูฟ้ามีวิชาที่ชอบเรียนแล้วก็ต้องมีวิชา
ที่แบบนึงไม่ชอบเรียน
ที่ครูฟ้าไม่ชอบเรียนวิชาอะไรมากที่สุด
คิดว่ากูฟ้ามีมากๆนะคะไม่ชอบเรียนๆหานัก
เรียนเยอะเลยเอาอะไรดีนะฟ้าไม่ชอบ
เรียนชอบมากๆ
หัวเราะอะไรเลือกไม่ถูกใช่ไหมคะ
มันเยอะนักเรียนได้คิดว่าภูเขาไม่ชอบเอา
มากๆไงห๊ะ
4th จ่ายค่ะ
เอา
อะไรดีนะ
อะไรอ่ะ
แล้วป้าไม่ชอบเรียนศิลปะหรอแบบวาดรูป
อย่างเงี้ยมีแบบมีจานสีใช่ไหมจานสีมีผู้
กันอันนี้วิชาศิลปะคู่ฟ้าไม่ชอบหรอไม่อ่ะ
คือแมกเนติกอ่ะกูฟ้าก็ไม่ชอบนะวิชาคณิต
อันเนี่ยวิทย์คณิตหรือว่าเลขเลขมาก็ไม่
ชอบเลขแต่ว่าก็ยังพอโอเคอยู่เพราะเรียน
เลขเยอะอยู่นะคะแต่กูความไม่ชอบอาร์ตแบบ
ไม่ชอบศิลปะไม่ชอบเลยแกะ Yeah
ไม่ชอบเลย
ทำไมคะทำไมว่านักเรียนอาจจะรู้ว่าครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เนี่ยกูก็มีขอไอแพดไหมมี iPad
เนี่ยวาดรูปชายแต่ครูฟ้าไม่ชอบเรียนวาด
รูป
ใช้เข้าไปเรียนศิลปะ
ไทยคือเวลาเรียนน่ะขวาจะบอกเลยว่ามันมี
เยอะนะว่าทำไมนะคะ 1
ครูฟ้าไม่ชอบครูต่อครูที่สอนวาดรูปเนี่ย
นะ
ทำไมคุณอิสรีย์พูดไม่ดี
ใช่อ่ะครูเนี่ยไม่โอเคเลยไม่ไม่ดีเลยฟ้า
ไม่ชอบไม่ชอบคุณครูนะคะค่ะ
ครูเนี่ยจะชอบมีให้วาดรูปใช่ไหมวาดรูป
บ้านวาดรูป
ถนนวาดรูปรถอะไรอย่างเงี้ยแล้วก็มันก็จะ
มีเกรดเนี่ย
กูฟ้าวาดรูปบ้านมาแล้วกูแต่ว่าอ่ะเอา
b.c.e. อะไรเงี้ยค่ะครูไม่ให้เอ๋ใครเลย
ค่ะไม่มี ay เลยมีแต่ B  +  4  +
ไหมแล้วครูก็พูดไม่ดีกว่าไม่ชอบนะฮะ 2
เวลาครูฟ้าเรียนศิลปะ
กูทำไม่มีฟิลลิ่งในการวาดรูปอ๋ออ๋อแบบผู้
ฟังไม่เชื่อคุณครูบอกฟ้าฟ้าวอ้านรูปบ้าน
แต่กูฝากแบบไม่อยากว่าด่าพ่อใช่หัก
จะบอกว่าอะไรมันก็เป็นคนที่ถ้าผู้ฟ้าจะ
วาดรูปว่าต้องอยากว่าเองถ้ามีคนบอกป๊าวาด
อันนี้ไว้แล้วรู้สึกว่าความไม่ชอบไม่มี
สิทธิ์ให้ครูฟ้าไม่ชอบให้ให้ครูหรือว่ามี
คนบอกช้าวาดรูปวาดรูปต่อไป
ไม่ว่าเราก็เลยจะเวลาที่เราเรียนศิลปะ
เรียนวาดรูปเนี่ยคุณครูจะบอกใช่ไหมฟ้าวาด
รูปภูเขาเนี่ยครูคุณครูเนี่ยจะบอกฝากเลย
บ่ไม่ชอบใช่แต่คุณจูเนี่ยไม่ได้บอกแล้วก็
สอนไงไม่ใช่การสอนใช่ไหมสมมุติถ้ากูฟ้า
อยากวาดรูปภูเขาครูก็จะบอกผู้ขาวต้องวาด
แบบนี้วาดแบบนี้โอเคไหมอันนี้คือการสอน
แต่คุณครูไม่สอนกูบอกอ่ะว่าอันนี้วาด
แอปเปิ้ลวันองุ่นวาดวาดวาดวาดวาดแล้วก็จบ
ครูไปนอนต่อฝาก็เลยแบบตอนเด็กๆก็เลยจำได้
ว่าไม่อยากเวลาคิด
13:00 นใช่ไหม 13:00 นต้องเรียนถ้า
ไม่ชอบไม่อยากเรียนให้ค่ะแล้วนั่นแหละก็
เลยไม่ชอบอ้าถ้าหากว่าอาร์ตคือ Art นะไม่
มีเกรดไม่มีเกรด A  B  C ไม่มีสวยไม่สวย
พวกมันคืออาตัดเรียนมี
ครูหญิงล่ะผู้หญิงไม่ชอบอะไร
ผู้หญิงไม่ชอบเรียนพละค่ะวิชาพละวิชาพละ
ก็คือวิชาที่เราจะเรียนวอลเลย์บอล
ฟุตบอลกูยังไม่ได้แกะเลยเหรอคะอันเนี้ย
ซื้อใหม่หรอได้ Op มีนานแล้วเราจะเรียน
ฟุตบอลนเรียนชกมวย
เรียนสกีใช่ไหมเรียนวิ่งอันนี้คือคือวิชา
พละเรียนกีฬาค่ะเรียนเต้น this นะคะวิชา
พละครูหญิงเนี่ยไม่ถ้าชอบเรียนวิชาพละมาก
ที่สุดตั้งแต่ผู้หญิงอายุ 7 ขวบจนครูหญิง
อายุ 18 ปีผู้หญิงไม่ชอบเลยวิชาพละ
ทำไมผู้หญิงไม่ชอบ
ครูหญิง
ผู้หญิงไม่ชอบหรือไม่ชอบเล่นกีฬาอาผู้
หญิงไม่ชอบวอลเลย์บอลไม่ชอบฟุตบอลไม่ชอบ
วิ่ง
ไม่สอบว่ายน้ำ
ไม่มีเลยเหรอผู้หญิงผู้หญิงชอบนี่เลยค่ะ
ไม่มีเลยใช่ไหมเวลาเรียนภาระเนี่ยเราต้อง
เล่นกีฬาคุณจะพยายามแกะอันนี้ออกมาให้นัก
เรียนดูนะคะผู้หญิงลืมไปว่าผู้หญิงไม่ได้
แกะนะคะได้ก็ได้นักเรียนนักเรียนอาจจะแบบ
ตกใจใช่ไหมเพราะว่านักเรียนมีท่อเรียน
วิชาพละวิชาพละเนี่ยเราไม่ต้องเรียน
เหนื่อยคุณครูแล้วบอกก็แค่ทุกคนเล่น
ฟุตบอลเย้สวยแต่ครูหญิงเนี่ย
ไม่ชอบเรียนเลยใช่ไหมถ้าคุณครูบอกว่าเล่น
ฟุตบอล
บาสเกตบอล
วอลเลย์บอล
ผู้หญิงไม่ชอบผู้หญิงไม่ชอบกีฬาทั้งหมด
เราเรียกว่ากีฬานัดผู้หญิงไม่ชอบกีฬาป้อง
ศูนย์เปอร์เซ็นต์
รู้ศูนย์เปอร์เซ็นต์กีฬาอาหารอย่างฟุตบอล
อย่างเงี้ยผู้หญิงไม่เล่นมาหาโรงเรียนไทย
เนี่ยฟุตบอลเนี่ยให้นักเรียนที่เป็นผู้
ชายผู้ชายเล่นฟุตบอล
แต่ผู้หญิงก็จะได้เรียน
Basket ต่อไม่ใช่เขาทุกท่านวอลเลย์บอล
ขวดเล่น
วอลเลย์บอลคุณครูเนี่ยก็คุณครูไม่ได้ให้
นักเรียนนักเรียนเนี่ยแบ่งทีมสมัยสมมุติ
มีนักเรียนผู้หญิง
คิดถึงปีกอ่ะนะมีนักเรียนผู้หญิงอ่ะสิบคน
คุณครูไม่ได้ให้แบ่ง 555 แล้วก็ 2 ทีม
แล้วก็เล่นไม่คุณครูแต่ให้เราเนี่ยมีลูก
ลูกวอลเลย์บอลแล้วก็เท่าไหร่นะท่าเนี้ย
ดอกดอกดอกดอกแล้วก็เสิร์ฟแต่ก็ดอกแล้วก็
เสิร์ฟแล้วก็ดอกผู้หญิงทำไม่ได้
อยากกอดมันยากอ่ะผู้หญิงทำไม่ได้เพราะทำ
ไม่ได้คุณครูก็แบบแม่ไม่โอเคคุยกันเลยใบ
ชอบเรียนพละไม่เสื้อกีฬาไม่ชอบเลยหายแต่
ครูฟ้าครูบาชอบไหมอ่ะเรียนพละลูกค้าก็ไม่
ชอบอ่ะมึงครูเป็นคุณครูผู้ชายชอบพูดกับ
ผู้หญิงแบบว่าไม่ดีนะคะเป็นเวลาเราเรียน
และก็จะมีคุณครูใช่ไหมครูอันนี้คุณครู
เนาะแล้วก็นี้นักเรียนผู้ชายผู้หญิงนัก
เรียนนักเรียนนักเรียนนักเรียนนักเรียน
นักเรียนแล้วก็คุณครูคุณครูผู้ชายและชอบ
พูดเสียงเนี่ย
เสียงจัง
แล้วก็ไปเอาพูดไม่ดีแล้วก็ชอบตีนักเรียน
ผู้หญิงใจค่ะผู้หญิงก็แพงไม่ชอบนะครับ
เป็นวิชาที่ไม่ชอบเรียนมากที่สุดนะวิชา
ภาระนักก็เด็กไอเหมือนกันนะคนไทยก็ไม่ชอบ
เรียนพละใช่ค่ะแต่เวลาดูวิชาพละของนัก
เรียนน่าสนุกสมัยครูแบ่งทีมแล้วก็เล่น
กีฬาเหมือนออกกำลังกายแต่โรงเรียนไทยไม่
นะคะได้ล่ะค่ะก็เป็นวิชาที่ครูหญิงแล้วก็
ครูฟ้าชอบเรียนแล้วก็ไม่ชอบเรียนนะคะไม่
รู้ว่าเหมือนกับนักเรียนไหมน้องนักเรียน
ชอบเรียนอะไรไม่ชอบเรียนอะไรก็คอมเม้นบอก
เราได้นะคะแต่ว่า
ตอนนี้อีกหมดเวลาแล้วแล้วก็เจอกันใหม่
วิดีโอหน้านะคะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะอ่ะ